time we discussed the sequence to
sequence or seek to seek architecture
where an encoder that is an RNN takes in
a sequence let's say a sentence and
compresses it to a fixed context vector
and a decoder RNN decodes this vector to
a translation. We discussed several
challenges that we had in this
architecture.
For example, we should wait for H2 to be
computed to be able to obtain H3. So
this means that we cannot really
parallelize this computation and we
cannot leverage the full potential of
our computational power uh in our GPU
and TPUs. Uh the other issue is of
course the old issue of uh gradient
vanishing and explosion because of the
fact that we are compressing everything
in this vector and we take it with us.
We try to take care of this with LSTM
and gating
and uh we manage to do a pretty good job
for short sentences but of course when
we have longer sentences the issue will
still be there. So this gradient
vanishing or explosion, we still have to
deal with this if we want to go for a
longer sentence translation for
instance. But the main problem here is
really this fixed bottleneck that we
have and we want to continue from there.
So here we will focus on this problem
first. Okay. So to make this uh fixed
bottleneck problem more clear maybe in a
translation task let's look at a French
to English translation. So here for
example we have a French sentence and
its translation in English. I want you
to pay uh pay close attention to things
that are making this fixed bottleneck
assumption more challenging. For
example, here we have this double
negation pair that is not the case in
English, right? That's one thing. The
order of adjective which is reverse in
the two language coming back to here for
example the second and fourth position
that are really the same uh is carrying
the same meaning should be coordinated
them but we here we separate them in
this. So we are asking RNN uh base seek
to seek that somehow compress all of
this structural information word
positions grammatical dependencies
semantic roles into this single fixed
dimensional vector but of course when
the sentence gets longer this becomes
more and more difficult. This is shown
in the original seek to sick paper at 20
2014 where uh the authors show the blue
score of the translation the grades for
sentences longer than 30 to 40 tokens.
Okay. So let's see how we can improve
this situation or redesign the
architecture to resolve this problem. C
and then we ask the decoder to decode
from there. And once we compute C we
basically we can throw away all of these
computations. So one idea is instead
each time when we decode we look at all
of these ages right. So this way we are
not really forgetting anything we keep
all of these memory bank uh or memory
slots and we access them to compute each
decoder state. So now assume that
somehow we are at the step uh or state t
or st of the decoder and we want to
compute st + one right and here the
decoder what decoder does is basically
first look at what we have generated so
far or st and it queries this memory
bank looks at each one of them to
basically see what information is
available and then it wants to compute
how relevant is this information or
basically where should I focus uh which
ones of this HDS are the most relevant
for this step of decoding and then it
wants to compute let's say an
intermediate context vector CT that is a
aggregation of all of these HDS uh
weighted by the relevance okay let's
give it a different index h from one to
at step t of decoding and waiting of
that hi.
So we want this weights to be normalized
to one to basically have a way of
pulling them. How can we uh obtain this
dynamic context vector as opposed to
previously fixed c.
uh so basically we are looking for
somehow a kind of a lookup mechanism
that the decoder wants to use to query
this memory bank and retrieve this
weighted combination of this encoder
states okay so this uh is very similar
to the regression problem that we had
for example we had x i yi
let's say we have n of them and then the
question is what if I have a new X that
is not in the training data. What is the
Y for that new X? The oldest way of
doing it is uh if we imagine X's for
example X1, X2 and X3
are somehow in this space and we want to
evaluate the value of a query let's say
X here. Let's call this query
here.
And we want to know how close this query
is to this axis. So we can compute some
form of distance. Right? So let's call
this distance here distance between Q
and X1.
And uh if you remember we compute the
distance between two data points using
some form of kernels. Going to use K
here. So this is the distance between
query of query Q and X1. This is Q and
X3
Q and X2 right and uh I call this Q and
let's call this F of Q right so we are
looking to compute F of Q okay so we
said F of Q is a weighted value of this
YI right because that's how we do
regression and these weights are
computed using this case of Q and this
X's. So since I want this WI to be
normalized, I'm going to use WI, which
is a function of Q. Of course, let's
call this EQ
uh from 1 to N. So WIQ will be K of Q
and X I normalized by sum of all of
these distances. So basically what we do
here is just a kernel regression right.
So this way we will compute f ofq or the
value of that query. So let's do some
changes of uh naming. So here instead of
yi I like to call them v i
instead of x i want to call them k i. I
already call this q and this is f ofq or
the value of q. Now let's just choose a
kernel here for example the the Gaussian
kernel and we can write it like this k
of q and x is an exponential of some
kernel bandwidth q - x 2. So we can
visualize this of course let's say in a
one-dimensional case for Q here we look
at the distance of course from Q to this
axis
and then we weight this distance with
this kernel function. So which is has
this form of Gaussian that we write it
down and we do this pooling based on
that K and that gives us the value of uh
F Q for that Q. We are connecting this
to what we were discussing that we want
to basically see the weights to tell the
decoder how much we want the decoder to
pay attention to this previous his which
is somehow a similarity based weights.
So in that case going back to the RNN
state what is the KIS? Uh the KIS will
be basically the HIS. The VIS are also
the HIS and the query was the ST and the
value of the query is SCT. Right? So we
use the similarity between ST and KI.
let's say using this kernel mechanism
and we find these weights and we pull
all of these values with those weights
and compute CT the result of that. So
instead of f of q here we call it
attention of q and here um so I had k
here for the kernel and k here for the
value it for the keys because I'm not
going to use this kernel anymore. I'm
going to use alpha if you remember. I'm
going to call K as the the vector of all
of the keys and V the vector of all of
the values. Okay.
So that will be the basically sum here.
So I'm just rewriting this in this new
nomenclature. So alpha I of Q and VI
from I 1 to T. Okay. So how we are
computing the alphas alphas just
basically very similar to what we did in
kernel regression and we need a function
that is taking in all of these weights
or kernels that we call here a and we
want this to be summed up to one. We
already have that function and that's
soft max. So this gives us the soft max
of
uh for i. This is basically a
normalization. Just to make it more
explicit, this uh is like a q ki
is somehow uh the log of the kernel
here. So this is like basically working
in this log space is just
computationally more convenient. We can
use gradient descent to optimize a
directly and uh exponential in soft max
converts this learned scores back to the
proper probability like weights. Okay,
so let's review what we did. We had this
fixed kernel just like the kernel
regression that we basically handcrafted
like this Gaussian kernel and we use
this ukidian distance and we find this
attention scores based on that. And uh
here the question is well what if that
kernel is not the best kernel right? So
we can do what we did before. Uh for
example in the case of convolutional
neural network we learn the filter or
the kernel there. Here we want to learn
this uh kernels also. And if we do it,
we basically have an attention mechanism
that is learning the kernel and finding
this relevancy between the state of the
encoder and this set of all of these
states in the encoder. So we are trying
to compute the similarity between ST and
HI like we discussed in the case that we
have the the kernel fixed here. We want
to learn that. So instead of uh
computing the similarity from the get-
go, we first apply like a linear uh
neural network. So a weight matrix over
S and then a weight matrix over HI and
then some activation let's assume 10
hyperbolic and then that's all the we
have to weight this also that is
basically like a scoring vector and this
will give us this score. Okay, this is
uh known as a additive attention and
it's the first time that the concept was
introduced back in 2014. So in the next
video we will talk about this and also
we discuss another variant of attention
that is the dot product attention trying
to do the same thing but in a more uh
computationally friendly Okay.